[Music]
I'm team Xbox ps4 into a lesser extent
Nintendo I'm Terry Crews and I'm team
pcmasterrace so Terry are you a gamer
yes I am so what type of games do you
play I feel like this is a setup
let me tell you about one game in
particular Madden you play Madden with
the joystick looking dead in the eye of
the person that you're beating right on
the same couch oh that's great but you
know what the thing is I I played an NFL
Ned man no console is a cheap cheap
imitation
using the console you got your little
all your little cheat codes know your
little moves and the whole thing it's
just always you and a buddy and bearded
hood you're not getting over stuff let
me take something he'll get anywhere
near my PC I got three words for you
Terry
okay Super Smash Brothers ever heard of
you okay but you know what's bad again
you've been living a JC Penney life it's
trying to step up the time for the the
brain rings you have to have your cable
management together if your cable
management is all jacked up you jacked
up I don't need to talk about wire
management cuz I've got the wireless
controller you can play in front of TV
you can play on the couch how many times
you're gonna take a PC to your couch no
no you never have a beginning you have a
nice beautiful desk set up you have
three monitors I don't have it yes all
right one screen isn't enough unless
there's actual human on the couch
playing there with you oh when are you
gonna do that with a PC but it's not
that good it's just not that good at
Optics but it just works Terry I just
plug it in I pay $60 a year and it just
works
oh man you know I'll put your life is it
your life's not working what evidence
have I given you the spider mouth I can
see you saw the pulse ox
this whole life isn't chef shuttle less
you owe me how this works go show me
really really set me up for that one
didn't it yeah dude go show me our works
will you well so first of all you click
the center screen Aden Meena mm-hmm I
said get up
show me PCs are trashed Terry Crews pcs
of trash go go Steam account that
together turn that off I don't want
anybody witnesses
you're and I'm turning the cameras off
no need any witnesses what's about to
happen
[Music]
Oh
[Music]